avoir un toit sur la tête c'est un
besoin vital une question de survie
pendant des milliers d'années les hommes
se sont fabriqué des abris en respectant
la nature en utilisant les ressources
locales
[Musique]
mais depuis 150 ans ce n'est plus le cas
il a fallu passer la vitesse supérieure
car la population mondiale a explosé
nous sommes déjà 7 milliards sur la
planète
et bientôt neuf
[Musique]
d'ici 2030 il faudra créer 4000
logements chaque heure pour répondre à
la demande
alors nous construisons toujours plus
haut plus vite plus gigantesque cette
boulimie de construction représente un
défi phénoménal pour l'environnement
car construire a un impact insoupçonné
sur la planète
[Musique]
la catastrophe à émettre autant de gaz à
effet de serre avec nos bâtiments
utilisés autant d'énergie à utiliser
autant de ressources en eau laissera
plus aux générations à tous
[Musique]
pour bâtir tous nos logements nous
piochons chaque année des millions de
tonnes de matières premières dans la
nature certains pays vont même jusqu'à
les volets
[Musique]
nos besoins en ressources naturelles
sont telles qu'ils finissent par
bouleverser la vie de populations
entières
avec 200 milles terriens de plus chaque
jour et des villes grossissant à
l'infini
loger tout ce monde est devenu une
priorité absolue avec un impératif qui
s'impose à tous réduire notre impact sur
l'environnement
et nous avons le pouvoir de le faire dès
aujourd'hui
nous pouvons par exemple revoir nos
modes de construction au lieu d'utiliser
du béton pourquoi ne pas bâtir nos
maisons avec des matières naturelles
comme le bois ou la terre
avons nous besoin de polluer autant pour
nous chauffer alors que nous pouvons
isoler nos logements avec des matières
naturelles ou même recyclés comme ces
vieux jeans broyé et compact et
nous avons aussi le choix de revoir nos
façons d'habiter sommes nous prêts à
partager nos lieux de vie pour réduire
notre facture sur la planète comme au
danemark des initiatives d'habitat
groupé voit le jour à grenoble ou à
strasbourg
et peut-être demain vivrons nous dans
ces villes du futur ou des immeubles
fourniront nourriture et énergie à leurs
habitants
[Musique]
autant de projets qui font place à la
nature
et nous rappelle qu'à ce jour
notre seul et unique maison
[Musique]
c'est la terre